HELLO AND WELCOME TO HAVE U.S.
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
ALL THAT ON THE WORLD.
I AM MICHAEL HOLMES, I'M HERE
IF YOU'RE ON CNN NEWSROOM?
THE.
AND OF AN ERA, ELECTION IN
GERMANY.
POLAR MARYLAND JUST IN FOR CNN,
AS TO WHICH PARTY HAS A LEG UP
IN ANGELA MERKEL'S MANTLE.
THE LEFT SWALLOWED CONDITIONS
OF THE U.S. BORDER ONLY TO
RETURN HOME TO SPIRALING
VIOLENCE IN HAITI.
PLUS, WE'LL TAKE YOU INTO THE
JUNGLES OF THE DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC OF CONGO, WHERE
EFFORTS ARE UNDERWAY TO SAVE
THESE ENDANGERED GORILLAS.
WELCOME EVERYONE, WE ARE
GETTING OUR FIRST LOOK AT THE
PRELIMINARY OFFICIAL RESULTS
FROM THE LANDMARK ELECTION IN
GERMANY.
NOW HERE ARE THE NUMBERS.
THEY SHOW THE LEFT LEANING
SOCIAL DEMOCRATS WINNING THE
MOST SEATS, INKING OUT A NARROW
LEAD OVER OUTGOING CHANCELLOR
ANGELA MERKEL'S CONSERVATIVE
BLOCK.
IT MARKS SOMETHING OF A SEA
CHANGE FOR THE SDP, WHICH HAS
PLAYED 2ND FIDDLE TO MISS
MERKEL'S CDU, DURING RECENT
YEARS.
OLAF SCHOLZ, THE SPD'S
CANDIDATE, ADDRESSING
SUPPORTERS ON SUNDAY.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE A LONG
ELECTION EVENING, THAT'S FOR
SURE.
BUT IT IS ALSO CERTAIN THAT A
LOT OF VOTERS HAVE KICKED OFF
IN FAVOR OF THE SPD, BECAUSE
THEY WANTED A CHANGE.
AND THEY WANTED THE NEXT
CHANCELLOR NAMED.
BUT THE CDC'S CANDIDATE, THE
PARTY THAT'S IGNITED SUCCESS
UNDER A CHANCELLOR MERKEL SAYS
SHOT --
HERE HE IS ADDRESSING
SUPPORTERS ON SUNDAY EVENING.
>> WE CANNOT BE CONTENT WITH
THIS RESULT.
THE OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION IS
STILL QUITE UNCLEAR.
IT IS GOING TO BE A LONG NIGHT.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, I ASSUME
THAT THERE WILL BE A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITH MOST LIKELY, 3
COALITION CANDIDATES.
WE, FROM THE CDC, WE HAVE BEEN
OBTAINING A CLEAR MANDATE FROM
THE VOTERS.
A VOTE FOR THE CDU IS A VOTE
AGAINST A LEFT GOVERNMENT.
NOW, IT'S ALL ABOUT ONE THING.
FOR THE STABLE COALITION, FOR
STRONG AND MODERN GERMANY.
>> NOW, BUILDING A NEW ROLLING
COALITION IS EXPECTED TO TAKE
WEEKS, PERHAPS EVEN MONTHS.
IT'S ALSO LIKELY TO REQUIRE
MEMBERS OF OTHER PARTIES LIKE
THE GREENS AND THE F-DP.
LEADERS SAY THEY HOPE TO HAVE A
NEW GOVERNMENT IN PLACE BY
CHRISTMAS, UNTIL THAT HAPPENS,
MRS. MERKEL WILL REMAIN IN
POWER.
>> FOR MORE, NOW CNN'S EUROPEAN
COMMENTATOR --
MOM FROM BERLIN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, DOMINIC.
BUT NOT THE 4 FORMS ANGELA
MERKEL WANTED FOR HER PARTY AND
PLENTY OF CORRELATION --
WHAT IS YOUR READ OF THE
RESULTS AND WHAT THEY TELL US
ABOUT THE MOOD OF GERMANS.
>> THEY TELL US AN AWFUL LOT.
I MEAN, IT'S SORT OF STAGGERING
IN A WAY, MICHAEL, IS THAT THEY
HAVE KNOWN FOR 4 YEARS THAT
ANGELA MERKEL WAS GOING TO STEP
AWAY FROM THE LEADERSHIP OF HER
PARTY.
AND YET, THEY FAILED TO FIND A
SUCCESSOR WHO COULD GALVANIZE
THE GERMAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S AFTER 16 YEARS IN POWER,
NOT ONLY DID THEY NOT COME OUT
AHEAD, BUT THEY'VE ACTUALLY
SCORED THEIR WORST SCORE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE PARTY.
AND I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO KEEP
EMPHASIZING.
IT'S ALSO THE BIGGEST DROP OF
ANY OF THE PARTIES RUNNING,
THIS TIME AROUND.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
AS THEY STAND RIGHT NOW, IT'S
INTERESTING TO SEE THAT,
BASICALLY, ABOUT 76% OF GERMANS
DID NOT VOTE FOR ANGELA
MERKEL'S PARTY.
WE SEE OTHER INTERESTING
THINGS.
THE OTHERS TO DROP, OF COURSE,
THE FAR-RIGHT AFD, WHO, ONCE
AGAIN, HAS NOT MANAGED TO SORT
OF CAPTIVATE PEOPLE AROUND ITS
SINGLE POLICY ANTI-IMMIGRATION.
AND THE AGE-OLD SORT OF LEGACY
OF THE FORMER GDR, DIE LINKE IS
ALMOST ON THE VERGE OF
EXTINCTION.
ALMOST BARELY MAKING IT INTO
PARLIAMENT.
SO HAVING SAID THAT, THE 3 THAT
HAVE GAINED OUR, OF COURSE,
OLAF SCHOLZ SDP AND THE GREENS,
AND THE F. D. P.
WHO NOW KNOW FULL WELL THAT
THEY WILL BE THE KING MAKERS IN
FORMING A COALITION, MOVING
FORWARD.
>> MERKEL, OF COURSE, HAD THIS
HIGHLY POLISHED REPUTATION
ABROAD, PERHAPS LESS THOUGH, AT
HOME, WITH HER POPULARITY
RAINING IN THE LAST WHILE.
SO, WHAT WILL GERMANS BE
LOOKING FOR IN THEIR NEW LEADER?
>> YEAH, WELL WHEN I THINK WE
ARE SEEING IS ESSENTIALLY THIS
COALITION IN WHICH THE SDP AND
THE CDU WERE TOGETHER IN
COALITION WITH MERKEL FOR 3 OUT
OF HER 4 CABINETS.
AND ESSENTIALLY, WHAT YOU HAD
WAS A SORT OF CENTER LEFT TO
CENTER RIGHT GOVERNMENT.
IT IS CLEAR NOW THAT WE HAVE
MOVED TOWARD A MORE CENTER-LEFT
ALIGNMENT, IN TERMS OF WHERE
THE GERMAN POPULATION SEES
ITSELF.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE CDU SORT OF
SCAREMONGERING, AS WE GO INTO
THIS COALITION TOP.
TRYING TO SORT OF SPREAD FEAR
ABOUT THIS BEING A KIND OF LEFT
ITS GOVERNMENT, WITH HIGHER
TAXES WITH SO ON AND SO FORTH.
THE REALITY, THOUGH, IS MUCH
CLOSER TO WHAT WE WOULD SAY
CONTINUITY.
EXCEPT FOR THE FAR-RIGHT AFD,
ALL OF THE MAIN POLITICAL
PARTIES UNDERSTAND THAT CLIMATE
MUST BE PUT AT FRONT AND
CENTER.
IT IS JUST THE DEGREE TO WHICH
AND THE AGGRESSIVE NATURE OF
THE POLICY CHANGES.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
INFRASTRUCTURAL CHANGES IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT, AND SO
ON.
BUT REALLY, WHAT WE ARE SEEING
HERE IS MORE OF A SHIFT TOWARDS
DOMESTIC POLICIES, TOWARD
THINGS THAT HAVE TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF IN GERMANY.
ESPECIALLY IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THE COVID PANDEMIC.
RATHER THAN GERMANY AS AN
EXTERNAL LOOKING OUT GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP KIND OF COUNTRY.
AND I THINK TO THAT EXTENT, THE
GLOBAL POPULATION IS GOING TO
HAVE TO RECALIBRATE, AS GERMANY
LOOKS INTERNALLY A LITTLE BIT
MORE AND, OF COURSE, WITH THIS
COALITION THAT WILL INVOLVE,
LIKELY 3 DIFFERENT PARTIES.
IT IS GOING TO BE A CERTAIN
KIND OF FRAGILITY, AND IT IS
GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF TENSION
AT HOME TO MAINTAIN THAT
CONTINUITY.
>> YEAH, FASCINATING.
OBVIOUSLY, THE ELECTION
IMPACTED GERMANS, OF COURSE,
BUT HOW MIGHT IT IMPACT THE
EUROPEAN UNION, GIVEN MERKEL'S
OWN ROLE AS A CONSTANT TO UNIFY
AN IGLOO, IN A WAY, THE EU.
>> I THINK THAT'S ALSO, LET'S
NOT, FORGET THAT EMMANUEL
MACRON, ANOTHER EU STAUNCH
DEFENDER IS UP FOR REELECTION
IN THE SPRING OF 2022.
WE ARE STILL REELING FROM THE
AFTERMATH OF THE PAST YEARS OF
NEGOTIATION AROUND BREXIT.
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY DID NOT
HELP, OF COURSE, WITH THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND THERE IS A KIND OF
FRAGILITY THERE, AGAIN, WHEN IT
COMES TO TALKING ABOUT EUROPE.
ANGELA MERKEL WAS CERTAINLY
VERY POWERFUL IN SORT OF
STAVING OFF SOME OF THAT
RIGHT-WING POPULIST KIND OF
RHETORIC AND TAKING ON THAT
SORT OF LEADERSHIP ROLE.
AND I THINK THAT ONE CAN EXPECT
A LESS OF A PRESENCE, THAT THE
INSTITUTION WILL CONTINUE, BUT
I THINK, ULTIMATELY, IT IS
WEAKENED AS ONE MOVES AWAY,
TOWARDS THESE OTHER SORTS OF
ISSUES.
AND IT IS GOING TO BE
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW THAT
ULTIMATELY UNFOLDS, ESPECIALLY
WITH THE RECENT NEW U.S.
PRESIDENCY AND SO.
ON AND THE TENSIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY THERE, ACROSS THE
ATLANTIC, WITH FRANCE, THE
UNITED STATES, AND SO ON.
>> AND IT'S A EUROPEAN ISSUE,
BUT ALSO A GERMAN ISSUE VERY
MUCH.
AND YOU TOUCHED ON THIS.
IMMIGRATION, REFUGEES A BIG
ISSUE IN GERMANY AND BACK IN
2015, AFTER THE BIG INFLUX,
THEY BOOSTED THAT ISSUE BOOSTED
THE FAR-RIGHT.
THE FAR-RIGHT IS HAS NOT DONE
WELL IN THIS ELECTION.
SO, WHERE DOES OPPOSITION GO?
WHERE DOES IMMIGRATION STAND AS
AN ISSUE?
>> YEAH, IT CONTINUES TO BE A
SUBJECT OF DISCUSSION.
BUT IT WAS CLEAR THAT 2015, IN
THE SO-CALLED MIGRANTS CRISIS,
REALLY HELPED THE FAR RIGHT
TAKE ON THIS KIND OF POLICY.
IT HIT INITIALLY BEEN AN
AUSTERITY PARTY, IT'S SORT OF
HITCHED ITS FORCE TO THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION.
AND AT THE TIME, IT WAS
INTERESTING TO SEE THAT NOT
ONLY WERE THEY, YOU KNOW, THE
2ND MAIN PARTY IN THE EAST OF
GERMANY, WHERE THERE WERE
ISSUES AROUND, OF COURSE,
IDENTITY, UNEMPLOYMENT, INCOME
DISPARITY.
BUT THERE WERE ALSO ABLE TO GET
A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF THE
VOTE IN WEST GERMANY, THAT THEY
HAVE GONE OVERALL FROM BEING A
3RD PARTY TO THE 5TH PARTY,
WITH BARELY 10% OF THE VOTE.
THE ISSUE THAT HAS MOVED ON.
IT IS NO LONGER SOMETHING THAT
TROUBLES THE GERMAN PEOPLE OR
THAT WAS INSTRUMENTALIZE.
WHERE DO YOU SEE AN ISSUE FOR
CONCERN IS HERE, WITH THE
UNLIKELIHOOD OF THE CDU ENDING
UP IN POWER.
AS THE CDU IN MANY WAYS,
IMPLODES AND RETHINKS ITS
AGENDA, THE QUESTION WILL BE
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THEY
ATTEMPT TO CAPTURE BACK SOME OF
THEIR ELECTORATE FROM THE
FAR-RIGHT AND TO GIVE OXYGEN TO
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AGAIN, AS
A WAY OF ATTRACTING THOSE
VOTERS.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT,
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND WE HAVE
SEEN THIS HAPPEN IN FRANCE.
WE CERTAINLY SAW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY IN
THE UK, AROUND BREXIT.
>> THAT IS A FASCINATING ASPECT.
--
MOVE THE PARTY SO MUCH THE
CENTER, WILL MAY NOT MOVE TO
THE RIGHT.
INTERESTING STUFF.